EVREN ERYUREK: Hello, everyone.
I'm Evren Eryurek.
Welcome to Streaming
Analytics on Google Cloud.
When you look at IDC,
they predict by 2025,
more than a quarter of the
data in the global datasphere
will be real time in nature.
Now, you may wonder,
why is this important?
It is important because
window of opportunity
in the real-time analysis
diminishes and goes away really
fast.
You want to be able to actually
respond to your customer
needs, their asks, be able to
do prediction or maybe detect
some problem and really
respond to it really fast.
While each and every
one of this data
becomes valuable for
retrospective analysis,
time to respond in real
time is very limited.
So you want to have
a platform that you
can achieve both
of these, real time
as well as a place where you
can do retrospective analysis.
And for that, you have Stream
Analytics on Google Cloud.
And this is the platform--
many of you out
there are already
providing various solutions
in your industries.
You have Pub/Sub on one end,
the Google native service
that entire Alphabet
company takes advantage of.
We made it available
through GCP for you
to take advantage of as well.
And you're doing a
great job in there.
That is your ingestion and
distribution of data, reliably,
globally.
And you have DataFlow
for all your data
processing, whether
it's streaming or batch.
Now you can do that.
And as you know,
in DataFlow, it's
the same set of code for
both streaming and batch.
And then you have the AI
Platform, BigQuery, BigTable,
Cloud SQL.
All of them are there
for your machine
learning needs, for your AI
needs and data warehousing
needs, to do more analysis
for your businesses.
Here are some examples
and great success stories.
Home Depot-- when they
started their journey
on the digital
transformation, when
they wanted to establish
this e-commerce platform
for themselves, they picked
Pub/Sub, Dataflow, and BigQuery
to do this thing.
And this allowed them
to really increase
new revenue opportunities
and reduce their churn.
When you look at
Palo Alto Networks,
they are building their
next-generation firewall
using Dataflow as an embedded
data processing system.
AirAsia uses the streaming
analytics platform
to provide refined pricing
for their customers.
This allowed them to
increase their revenue
and improve customer
satisfaction and customer
experience.
ULTA Beauty has established
their e-commerce platform where
they can actually
provide real-time offers
to their users, and suggestions
based on their shopping
practices and search
practices and so forth,
again using this
real-time analytics
platform for their shoppers.
Now, in this platform, in
your own organizations,
you have some heroes out there.
Your data analysts,
your engineers,
your data scientists,
and your operators
are out there making this
work for your systems,
for your customers.
And throughout my
conversation today with you,
I'll be highlighting
what we are doing
to make their lives
easier, more effective,
and also bringing some
cost saving opportunities
for all of you out there.
Here's a snapshot of
what you're going to hear
for the rest of my talk.
You will hear Dataflow SQL.
We're actually really happy.
All the feedback that
we've gotten from you
on the early releases--
you're loving this thing.
It made it much easier for
your analysts and engineers.
You're really enjoying the
AI Platform integration
with Dataflow.
And Jupyter Notebooks
was one of those things
that data scientists
really, really asked for it.
And here you go.
You have an integrated
and seamless experience
from many of our
services on Google Cloud,
including Dataflow.
And operators have asked
for some dashboard,
some real-time
analysis capabilities,
and a lot more in here.
We're going to go into it.
Ready?
Let's go.
Let's start with
the ingestion first.
I mentioned, Pub/Sub is
one of those services
that we across
Alphabet leverage.
And we made it available.
It's a globally scalable,
fantastic technology--
really, really good.
We did hear loud and
clear from all of you
that you wanted message
ordering and dead letter topics.
And thank you for your patience.
Now, they are going to
be available for you.
We also heard some cost
saving opportunities
where you asked for a
service like Pub/Sub Lite.
I'm going to go into
it a little bit more.
And it gives you cost-optimized
event ingestion and data
messaging platform
for your zonal needs.
A very global nature may
not be necessary for you.
So we created in here--
our objective was to
make it so compelling,
even for your do-it-yourself
Kafka solutions
that you may have, it is going
to be a higher cost than what
we can provide to you.
And of course, through our
Confluent Cloud partnership,
we have a fully
managed Kafka service
for all your on-prem to
cloud migration needs.
And CDC was one of
those capabilities
that you've been asking for.
And I'm going to give you
a couple examples of what
is coming up for you.
Here is a Pub/Sub Lite.
So this is possibly
the lowest cost
to start possible messaging
and event messaging system
that you can find in here.
It's ideal for
predictable workloads.
It's zonal, so that
you can actually
figure out where to do it.
It's really easy to configure
and already seamlessly
integrated with Dataflow, rest
of Google Cloud Data Analytics
Platform, and GCP services.
So give it a try if
you haven't used it.
We believe it will be much
easier for you to really take
advantage of Pub/Sub Lite
than do-it-yourself Kafka-like
environment that you may have.
If you have a lot
of Kafka workloads,
and you are migrating to
Google Cloud, you are using--
or you should be using--
Confluent Cloud.
We have seamlessly
integrated with our partners.
They are integrated just
like Pub/Sub with Dataflow
and all our other
GCP services for you
to achieve your Kafka
workloads as you
are migrating towards GCP.
And CDC-- this was your ask.
And here's two options for
you that we're actually
providing you.
And for your MySQL and
Postgres use cases,
we're building a
solution with Debezium.
It's available as an open
source, self-managed template.
As a fully-managed template
solution from ourselves,
we're bringing you--
through our Datastream,
you will have a CDC capability
for Oracle Databases.
Through Datastream, through
Dataflow, through BigQuery,
you'll be able to provide
this CDC capability.
This has been one of those asks.
And we're happy to show you
what's coming up for you.
For all data engineers and
some pipeline development--
that's key.
I highlighted the Dataflow SQL.
It's for you to really
take advantage of SQL.
It's the same
dialect that we have
with our BigQuery and Spanner.
You'll be able to
do kind of joins
within the Pub/Sub streams,
and BigQuery tables,
and GCS files, and so forth.
You will do some schema supports
using the Visual Editor.
It's right there for you.
Your early responses
were very, very positive.
If you haven't
started using it, I
encourage you to really
take a look at it.
You'll be able to build your
real-time dashboards based
on BigQuery.
Do your transforms.
Start there-- very easy.
Go at it if you haven't
started using it.
Data scientists have been
asking for this Jupyter Notebook
integration with Dataflow,
so that you can actually
do your own
interactive development
prototyping in the environment
that you're so used to it.
Now, Dataflow is integrated
into Jupyter Notebooks.
Go ahead and do it.
You have the interactive
runners there, all the support
that you need for your AI
Platform on Google Cloud.
It's the same experience.
So this was something
you've been asking for.
I'm really happy to announce
that it is in your hands.
Now, this is a good one--
Flex templates.
As you know, we provide
25 different templates
through our Dataflow UI
and CLI for you to take
advantage of as a template.
One of the asks that
many of you had was,
hey, I built these Dataflow
pipelines into my system.
But I want to turn
this into a template,
so the rest of my organization
can use it as well,
within my own team, within
my own organization.
Now, you can do that.
This was something
that you asked for.
It's a much better system.
And you're used to it.
You created it.
It's all yours along with
the 25 that we provided.
Quick Recommendations--
this is a really interesting
capability.
So it actually
provides you guidance
for your data analysts, data
engineers, data scientists.
And it achieves some
cost saving along
the way where you can actually
get some recommendations.
Hey, do it this way
and do it that way.
Maybe clean your Datastore
databases or extra entities.
Find different
ways to restore it
and backup and restore
Spanner, what have you.
It provides you, through
these recommendations,
ways to really improve it.
What is it that you can do?
And it is all in the
fingertips of yours.
Performances scale.
This is always a
paramount for us.
This is always top of mind.
We always figure out a way
to make it faster, easier,
and scale even
bigger and broader.
Here's one-- FlexRS.
If you haven't heard,
this is a fantastic
cost-saving opportunity for you.
You could save up to 40% of
your cost in some of your batch
workers.
If you have a job that
you run daily or weekly,
you don't have to worry about
changing a single line of code.
All you have to
do is turn it on.
Add one pipeline option.
That's it.
But remember, this needs
to be one of those jobs
that you run daily
or weekly, because it
might take a few hours
to find the most cost
optimum environment
for it to run.
So that's why it's says in here,
it may delay up to six hours.
Here's what we have done
for the Beam community.
The Dataflow Runner
v2 is available.
It has a lot more
capabilities in there,
from more I/Os, including
Kafka I/O and so forth,
to parity across SDKs,
including the state and timer
support in Python.
It's available right now for
you to test with your Python
streaming pipelines.
Go at it.
And try it.
You will find some cost-saving
opportunities there, all of you
data engineers out there.
And thank you for really
taking advantage of the Beam.
And our operators, for you--
you've been asking
this dashboard.
Now, all your important
pipeline metrics
in a single time-correlated
dashboard is ready.
It's available for you.
You'll be able to go
deep dive into it.
Understand how we are making
some of these autoscaling
decisions.
That was somewhat of a
mystery for all of you.
And you've been asking for it.
So we're providing some of
this visibility and actually
some cost reductions as well.
So you can optimize
your own pipelines,
latencies, and throughputs
as you're going at it.
And these are all
in your fingertips.
And keep asking.
Keep pushing us in this area.
Managed pipelines--
this is another one
that you've been asking.
Now, you'll be able to
understand resource allocations
over multiple job executions
that you may have.
And this actually
enables you to really
give you better freshness
on installers and so forth.
Drill down on your pipelines.
Maybe figure out some
problems that you
may be seeing at the end,
and fix it, and optimize it.
It's much easier
for you to do it.
We're going to continue
to invest in here.
Ease of use is paramount for us.
We really, really want to
make it easier for you.
Now, real-time AI--
as an AI student,
I'm always excited about
what we're doing in here.
So we've been working with our
partners across the ecosystem
and trying to figure out
what is it that we can do,
and how is it that we can
actually create some patterns
and create some kind of
easy-to-start templates
and sample codes and so forth by
integrating Dataflow and Cloud
AI Platform for
pattern recognition,
anomaly detections, and
predictions and forecasting
and so forth, for every
industry you can think of,
from media to retail to
health care to fintech.
You name it.
There's some great
capabilities out there.
You can use structured
and unstructured data
for your pattern recognition.
You can use it with your videos.
You can use it with images
and text and so forth.
Now, here's an
example from Telus.
A great team in Canada, they are
one of the largest and fastest
growing telecom companies.
And they have many,
many events coming in.
And they wanted to
actually use Dataflow
to detect some anomalies
in their network.
So we're looking at
250,000 events per second
that they process.
And they figure out,
are there any anomalies
that we need to be
really looking at it
and detect it in a timely
manner and respond to it?
This is one of those use
cases where you really
need to detect fast
and respond fast.
And Telus team has done a
fantastic job taking advantage
of this platform,
these capabilities
that we provided with Dataflow.
And there is a lot
more to do there.
You can do it in every industry.
If you visit our website, you
will see a lot more in there.
And the codes are
ready for you to take
advantage of from GitHub.
Let's wrap it up together.
We are the leader in
streaming analytics
when you look at
Forrester's Streaming Wave.
There are a lot of
things that makes
us the leader in this area.
There are five
criteria that we've
been rated the highest in here.
Many of you are already
taking advantage
of these capabilities.
And we invite all
of you to come.
Take a look at it.
Visit.
Ping us.
Chat with us.
There is a way we can help you
with all your needs in here.
Here is a list of you out
there doing wonderful things
everywhere in the world, from
retail to transportation,
from health care to gaming
to media to fintech.
All of you have built great
solutions on these technologies
that I just spoke about.
Thank you for everything
that you're doing.
Thank you for all
your use cases,
and challenging us,
and working with us.
We're looking forward to really
hearing more of your feedback.
We're here to really
work with you.
Here's a wrap up for you.
We talked about what we've
done for data analysts, data
engineers, data
scientists, and operators.
There's a lot more out
there if you go and visit
our streaming analytics
website in Google Cloud.
You will find many blogs, many
links to the code repositories,
and so forth, to
really make it easy.
But if you're still
having problems, ping us.
Ping me.
Find me at wherever you can.
We'll get you going right away.
Thank you for your time.
We really appreciate it and
hope you had a wonderful time.